cómo evalúa los anuncios en materia de
inclusión social e inflación massa dijo
que en agosto anunciará refuerzos que
ayude a los jubilados a superar el daño
de la inflación que trabajará para que
los trabajadores recuperen sus ingresos
y un reordenamiento de planes sociales
bueno fueron anuncios de objetivos que
en principio están bien orientados lo
que no quedó claro todavía son cómo va a
implementar esas medidas porque entre
esas medidas además de las que usted
mencionó está llegar a la reducción del
déficit equivalente al 2.5 por ciento
del producto comprometida con el fondo
monetario lo que también va a haber
necesidad de
reducir el gasto público y sobre todo
reducir los subsidios vinculados con la
energía que son aproximadamente un 2.5
del producto
si precisamente massa se refirió a la
crisis energética global para justificar
una nueva política tarifaria se estima
que alrededor de un 30 por ciento de los
hogares perderá el subsidio en los
servicios de luz gas y agua qué
consecuencias podría tener esto
para las consecuencias son las lógicas
pagar por la energía lo que es lo que
sale
en realidad nosotros en argentina bueno
yo no vivo en argentina que rato pero en
argentina la gente está acostumbrada
hace muchos años a pagar tarifas por la
energía eléctrica y por el gas que no
representan en lo más mínimo el costo de
producción y distribución
eso tiene varios problemas primero
la gente gasta más energía de la que
debería gastar tengo es una forma de
subsidiar emisiones también temo que el
problema es que hace tanto tiempo que se
viene pagando mucho menos de lo que sale
mirar una especie de acostumbramiento y
en un momento de digamos de crisis
económica y de malestar social eso va a
ser particularmente difícil
si todo este plan de gestión cómo podría
impactar en el acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional ya el miércoles
hubo una reunión de trabajo con
representantes del fmi
por lo que plantea más a sí lo puede
llegar
a implementar y en buena medida depende
del apoyo político
del propio frente de gobierno del propia
coalición de gobierno del frente de
todos que tenga y su capacidad de más de
armar consensos con la parte más
moderada de la oposición si puede hacer
eso que el anuncio yo creo que va a
repercutir positivamente
digamos que va a ser va a ver que el
programa con el fondo tiene tres
elementos básicos unas son las las metas
cuantitativas que en principio nos están
moviendo después hay otros dos elementos
que son los plazos para llegar a las
metas y las medidas el gobierno tiene
que tomar para llegar a esas metas en
los plazos pasa lo que está diciendo es
voy a
acelerar esas medidas voy a tomar
medidas que hasta ahora no se han tomado
bueno si él logra hacer esto yo creo que
el fondo probablemente pueda mostrar
flexibilidad respecto a los plazos